joining me now is Florida Congressman
Byron Donalds of the house oversight
committee and Ben domenic
editor-at-large of The Spectator and Fox
News contributor Congressman
um I think this is in the process of
backfiring on the Democrats they really
did think that trying to humiliate Trump
and Fulton County would be just one more
nail in his coffin his political coffin
I don't see it
neither do I Laura I think what people
are looking at is that this the system
run by the Democrats the justice system
run by the Democrats is being wielded
for Pure politics just so they can get
their their proverbial at a scratch
itched it's ridiculous and frankly as
destructive of our country meanwhile all
the things that are going on in America
that are affecting poor Americans
middle-income Americans white Americans
black Americans Etc is being ignored and
the Press covers it up this is going to
backfire in a major way because
Americans want our country to function
they don't want it to be used as a
political weapon against political
rivals now Ben you made some of these
great points on my podcast this week but
I want to reiterate something here once
in a while even one of the reporters at
the other networks gets a light bulb
watch this
this primary electorate really wants
someone who they feel are fun is
fighting for them they want someone who
is flexing their muscles and showing
that in fundraising in fighting The
Establishment even though the
establishment here is the criminal
justice system
that's a CNN political reporter actually
saying what the GOP electorate wants to
see he's a lot better than that trash
analyst John heilman who you made me
watch more than I've had to see in many
years no I accept your apology look they
have run into something I think here
that they have completely underestimated
which is they have devoted so much of
their time to trying to go after the
former president that they have failed
to have any kind of agenda that was
promised by them in the 2020 election
anything that would actually satisfy the
demands of working people across this
country the demands of the middle class
they've treated the failure of the in
inflation reduction act as if it was
something that was just you know a speed
bump something along the road to just
inevitable re-election when in reality
what they've done is taken their eye off
the ball and now they're trying to make
up for it by saying well you can't
re-elect this guy because he's so
dangerous he's so dangerous to you know
democracy and the Constitution and the
like but when people see something like
this I think it makes things very real
for them the idea of looking at an image
a mug shot of a former president it's
kind of disgusting in a way that I think
that will actually lead to a backlash a
serious backlash against the Democrats
who have pursued this no one wants to
see this they don't think that it's the
right thing to do to any for any former
president you know Republicans didn't go
after Bill Clinton you know after he
left office we didn't see the kind of
you know going after George W bush you
know over you know Iraq war war crimes
or whatever you you know wanted to
suggest the same with Barack Obama and
now Donald Trump gets this kind of
treatment
this may be the first mug shot that we
have of a former president but they're
setting it up so it won't be the last
and that's the thing that I think
they're underestimating about this whole
scenario they have opened up a Pandora's
Box and they don't know what's going to
come next yeah
because I'm sensing it across
ethnicities uh racial lines uh and
African-American men
after telling them for years that the
justice system is corrupt and crooked
they're looking at this you know in some
of the videos we've seen today and
featured they're looking at some of this
going whoa whoa whoa now they're
targeting him do you see that or am I
overstating it
no you're absolutely right Lord Lord
that's what's happening and look
Americans are pissed off you're talking
about a government a department of
justice that ignores the crimes of the
president's son and frankly the
president himself they ignore those
crimes there's no investigation there's
no serious effort by the Department of
Justice or the FBI to get to the bottom
of that meanwhile they're going after
the chief political arrival that is
unfairness to the nth degree and all
that is happening with the backdrop of
an America that is failing around US
border policy inflation fentanyl on our
streets questioning the gender of
children that is something that speaks
frankly to all men not just black men
because we just want the country to
function and this foolishness by the
Democrats they're going to rule the day
that they wasted all of our time with
this because I believe there will be a
backlash in 24. yeah I think I don't
like the phrase pissed off but it really
does apply here to the way most people
are feeling about what they're seeing
around them Congressman Ben thank you so
much I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade
and I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis